for us you know there is no set leader
on our team you know we we need
everybody to be leaders you know we need
you know no matter if you're a rookie if
you're you know an eight year nine year
guy uh i think we got to start with with
a clean slate and i think we got the
right guys you know we're we've got a
young group who's hungry we got a good
mix of veteran leadership and
you know i think it's just taking it day
by day
christian mccaffrey joining us at the
super bowl just weeks after becoming the
third player in league history to have
1 000 yards rushing 1 000 yards
receiving in the same season he had
completed his third nfl season the
window was open for a second contract
and chris i firmly believe that
christian mccaffrey was not going to
show up for anything this year in
carolina until he got paid and with cam
newton gone luke keatley retired the
last thing that david tepper the still
fairly new owner of the panthers needed
was a fight with the new face of the
franchise so before it ever got to the
point where he skipped anything even one
virtual off-season training session
we'll talk about that program coming up
later in the program
the panthers got this guy paid 16
million per year in new money on a
four-year extension for christian
mccaffrey he's under contract for six
more seasons with the panthers and he's
now the highest paid running back in
league history which is more than fair
because he has shown us that he's more
than a running back he's a running back
and he's a receiver and he's the best
weapon offensively that the panthers
have and if you're paying teddy
bridgewater 21 yeah
christian mccaffrey's worth 16.
well yeah exactly i mean that just that
tells you the state of the running back
position right off the bat a guy like
teddy bridgewater who's kind of a
journeyman is going to make more money
than the best running back in the game
now you're right mike with christian
mccaffrey the i mean that's that's the
big point there i mean keekly gone cam
newton gone man you want to piss off
your fan base and not sell out a stadium
then not have christian mccaffrey there
as well you're right he was the face of
the franchise is the face of the
franchises today added to the fact
the leverage he had because of his x's
and x and o value you know that's the
other way mike he had tremendous
leverage over tepper and the carolina
panthers because not only does tepper
realize that but when you have matt rule
come in who hired joe brady from
louisiana lsu
okay who runs the sean payton offense
schematically
the coaches are are under the night
under the gun a little bit because they
know how important a guy like christian
mccaffrey is to make that offense happen
roger craig was in a similar offense
that's why he was awesome well christian
mccaffrey yes he is going to be the
alvin kamara for sean payton but also be
the latavius murray or mark ingram
whatever you want to say he does both to
your point and that's where he had real
leverage over the football team in my
opinion
53 of all touches last year for the
panthers that led the nfl 44 of the
team's yards from scrimmage that was
first in the
in the nfl he had 2 392 yards from
scrimmage and uh he scored 51
of the team's scrimmage touchdowns last
year that was also first in the nfl and
just last week new coach matt rule said
of mccaffrey to label him a tailback
that's not respectful to him he's a
tailback slash wide-out he can do it all
now look that's the kind of thing that
forces you to pay even more money but my
guess is when matt rules said that last
week they already knew what they were
going to put on the table and they had a
pretty good idea that mccaffrey was
gonna take it and there was a a a while
and i i heard some of the stuff that was
going on behind the scenes and it had
not yet gotten to the point where there
was any acrimony or consternation look
this guy's represented by joel siegel
who got khalil mack out of oakland after
a lengthy and ugly off-season dispute in
2018. he got deforest buckner out of san
francisco this year he engineered the
trade to the colts for the 13th overall
pick in the draft because the 49ers
didn't want to pay buckner so i think
the panthers just knew
that this goes sideways quickly and the
next thing you know the agent gets the
idea in the player's head the only way
you're going to get paid is to go
somewhere else and there was already
people saying boy would it be great to
get him to the denver broncos playing
with with for john elway where his dad
played now obviously with melvin gordon
there that kind of got blown up but
there was already some
where could christian mccaffrey go if
not carolina and i think the panthers
knew they needed to get this thing done
to prevent any of that talk from ever
hitting anyone's radar screen
well you're right i mean first off we
know being in the business the agent
aspect of this whole conversation is
real and joel siegel he doesn't play
games i mean he's he's known to be
you know a hardball player he is he
makes aggressive moves for his players
that he represents and you're right i
don't think he would have had any
problem kind of uh amping up the
intensity in this conversation if he
felt like he wasn't gonna get the number
he deserved so you know that's very real
to your matt rule who you said you know
said all those nice complimentary things
i i wouldn't be shocked if matt rule
said those things to make sure ownership
knew hey like we need this guy if you
just hired me and gave me nine million
dollars to coach your football team i'd
like to get some wins here in the first
year and christian mccaffrey is going to
be paramount in making that happen so
he's a huge part of what they do we know
that he's super talented mike and you
know here's a guy again i'm rooting for
him just because i like him but also for
future running backs i mean we've seen
the blow that the running back market's
taken and this guy is special but man
403 touches last year
you know th this is going to be
a a really good test to see where he's
at you know next year the year after the
next two or three years he really takes
care of his body we know that he had a
lot of carries at stanford too so he's
showing he's able to be durable that way
but uh this is this is a big move for
the carolina panthers and i completely
understand them paying a guy like
christian mccaffrey
we've seen second contracts for running
backs not work out they are taking a
calculated risk here they paid him early
he's not even 24 years old yet but chris
you're right there's only so much gas in
that tank a lot of touches at stanford a
lot of touches once things got rolling
for him in carolina early on i didn't
think they were using him enough to
justify making him the eighth overall
pick in the draft they're using him more
and more and more now and he's the guy
and they are going to get full value out
of that 16 million per year and i think
they knew deep down he really wasn't
inclined to mess around he's not going
to wear it on his sleeve but remember he
he made a business decision at stanford
didn't play in the bowl game as last
year there and one thing not a lot of
people know pre-draft back in 2017 when
he was entering the nfl he said no to
all private workouts he gets it he
wasn't going to put his body at risk he
understands what's at stake and now he's
gotten the big payday and he deserves
every penny of it we'll see if at some
point one year two years three years
four years down the road the panthers
think they got a value or they think
they paid too much
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports